hey this is presh talwalkar
a table lists a series of inputs and
outputs
the input of one goes to the output of
five
two goes to the output of ten
three goes to the output of 55
for the input value of 10 what is its
output value
and what is the rule between the inputs
and outputs
this question was given to gifted
eight-year-old students and i saw it on
reddit homework help
many of the adults thought this was too
hard of a question to give to
eight-year-old students
in fact some of them speculated there
must be a typo in the question
the output value for 3 should not be 55
they speculated that it should instead
be equal to 15.
then we would have a simple rule
the outputs would be equal to 5 times
the inputs which would mean
that the output for 10 would be equal to
50.
however i don't think we can just say
that it's a typo
but forget for a moment that this
question was given to eight-year-old
students
just consider that we have this set of
inputs and this set of outputs and we
want to determine a rule between them
what could the rule be and what would
the output value for 10 be
this is still a challenging and
interesting question
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
as specified there are actually
infinitely many functions that could
determine a rule between the inputs and
outputs
consider a general piecewise defined
function f of x
where its value at 1 is equal to 5
its value at 2 is equal to 10
its value at 3 is equal to 55
and for all other x values it's equal to
some other function g of x
in that case the function could even be
undefined at the input value of 10.
it could also be any value that we
specify
so as stated this problem
could have an infinite number of
solutions
but remember that it was given to gifted
eight-year-old students so we would
instead be looking for a simple rule
in that case imagine we're looking for a
function that's a polynomial
now we know that these three points
don't all pass through the same line
so what kind of polynomial would we be
looking for
well it's not a linear polynomial it
would be a quadratic polynomial
so consider a function f of x that's
equal to ax squared plus bx plus c
from the given information we're going
to solve for the values of a b and c
f of one is equal to five
so we substitute that in f of one is
equal to five which is equal to a
multiplied by one squared plus b
multiplied by one plus c
we'll then substitute for f of two
f of two is equal to ten and we'll
substitute that x is equal to two
we'll do the same thing for f of three
we now have a system of three
let's simplify each of these equations
f of one is equal to five which will be
equal to a plus b plus c
f of two is equal to ten which will be
equal to four a plus two b plus c f of 3
is equal to 55 which is equal to 9a plus
3b plus c
let's now solve this system of equations
for a b and c
let's subtract the following two
equations and eliminate the c variable
we'll get that five is equal to three a
plus b
now we'll take a copy of this first
equation and subtract it from the
equation that's equal to fifty-five this
will also eliminate the c variable
we get 45 is equal to 5a plus b
if we take the equation on the left and
then subtract it from this equation
we'll eliminate the b variable
so we get that 40 is equal to 2a which
means a is equal to 20.
from here we can go to the following
equation and substitute in a is equal to
20.
this means 5 is equal to 60 plus b which
means b is equal to negative 55.
then we have 5 is equal to a plus b plus
c we'll substitute for a and b and we
can solve that c is equal to 40.
so we put this all together we've solved
for a b and c
and we had defined the function f of x
as equal to ax squared plus bx plus c
so we substitute in the values of a b
and c
so f of x is equal to 20x squared minus
55x plus 40.
finally we need to know what happens
when x is equal to 10.
we substitute x is equal to 10 and we
carefully simplify this to get that f of
10 is equal to 14 90 and that's the
missing value
so what do you think was this a
challenging problem for you and did you
have as much fun solving it as i did
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of find your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you